[THEME MUSIC]
GABE WEISS: Hi.
Welcome to "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
I'm Gabe Weiss.
Shared file storage
is the unsung hero
of application development.
Pick the right solution, chances
are, no one's going to notice.
But pick the wrong
solution, and you'll
be chasing bottlenecks for days.
No one knows this better than
our partners over at NetApp.
And today, I've got Oliver
Krause, technical marketing
engineer from NetApp, to tell
us about a great solution
for Windows file sharing.
Oliver, why don't
you take a second,
introduce yourself, and
tell us a little bit
about what you and NetApp do?
OLIVER KRAUSE: Hi, Gabe.
Thanks for having me.
So I'm Oliver, located
in Germany near Munich.
Over 20 years ago, I
started at a storage startup
called NetApp.
It became a unicorn.
And today, it's one
of the biggest storage
and data management
companies in the world.
I held many different
positions in that company,
usually in presales
positions, helping customers
solve their storage problems.
And a few years ago, I switched
into our cloud business
simply to help do new
stuff in the cloud world.
GABE WEISS: Glad to have you.
So Oliver, I've got
a Windows application
and I want to run
it in the Cloud.
But I know there are a ton
of file storage solutions
out there.
Maybe you could tell
us just a little bit
about what's out there,
and some pros and cons.
OLIVER KRAUSE: Yeah,
in the storage world,
we have three different
kinds of storages.
The first one is a
traditional disk,
like a hard disk or an
SSD, or a USB stick.
It's basically a disk which
you plug into a computer
into your computer, put a
file system on top of it,
and use it locally.
It's also called block storage.
After some time,
people thought, oh, it
would be cool if we
could use that file
system on that disk on multiple
computers, so share the data.
And don't share
it on a disk base,
but share it on a per file base.
So basically, file
sharing was invented.
Some file sharing file
systems were invented.
And people were able to use
data on multiple VMs or multiple
computers in that time.
And then the new
kids on the block
is object storage, like
Google Cloud Storage.
It uses HTTP to store data.
Relatively new, let's say
10 years or something.
And it's a great way to
store unstructured data.
But most of the enterprise
applications in enterprise data
centers still don't
talk object, but we
talk file NAS to share data.
GABE WEISS: So people just
say, like, just lift and shift.
It's so easy.
But clearly, if your application
doesn't speak object storage,
that's not going to be so easy.
So you've been around.
What specific
challenges have you
seen in terms of shifting
a Windows application up
to the cloud?
OLIVER KRAUSE:
OK, yeah, so let's
assume we want to do a lift
and shift with the Windows
application.
And that application
requires data
sharing between multiple
VMs, which is, by the way,
a very common scenario.
To enable that, you first
need to deploy a GCE instance
with Windows--
with operating system running.
You need to size
your VM incorrectly.
Eventually, you
have to patch it,
keep up with the latest patches.
You have to monitor it.
Maybe the performance
requirements change,
so we have to resize it.
You have to think about
backup and recovery,
and maybe even make it highly
available-- so multiple sounds
and so on.
And after you did
all of that, then you
can start to attach a data disk,
put a file system on top of it,
and share it via the SMB
protocol to other machines.
GABE WEISS: So hang on.
You mentioned SMB.
Some folks might not
necessarily know what SMB is.
Could you just
explain real quick
what that is, and
maybe compare it
to what folks might be
more familiar with NFS?
OLIVER KRAUSE: Yeah, so to
share out the local file system,
which is on a disk, in
a computer, if you want
to share it out to
different computers,
you need a protocol to access
the file system over a network.
In the old days, most
systems have been Unix.
And NFS was invented, Network
File System, which is still
used in Unix-based or
Linux-based systems today,
and very popular.
In the Windows world,
Microsoft invented
SMB, which is an abbreviation
for Server Message Block.
In the beginning, it was
not a very good protocol.
But anyway, in the
2000s Microsoft
renamed it CIFS, "sifs," which
stands for Common Internet File
System.
Everything had to be
named internet something.
Later on, Microsoft
renamed it back to SMB.
Today, we have SMB version
2.1, and very recently 3.0,
which are very good
and capable protocols.
GABE WEISS: Got it.
And I know, Cloud Volume
Services, or CVS for short,
supports both SMB and NFS.
So this leads nicely into what
we want to talk about today.
So to start, why don't you
just tell us, what is CVS?
OLIVER KRAUSE: CVS is
net shares as a service.
You create a volume and
share it via NFS or SMB,
or both, to your clients.
And since it's a
service, it is super
easy to use and to consume,
and trouble-free to manage.
GABE WEISS: And how does
CVS help us specifically
with a Windows
migration, for example?
OLIVER KRAUSE:
Yeah, like I said,
if you do it with
a Windows way, you
have to manage a Windows VM
with all the adjacent problems.
CVS, in contrast, is a service.
So you can easily
create volumes.
You can scale them up and
scale them down, both capacity
and performance-wise.
You pay per gigabyte per
month, just like you do
with persistent disks and GCS.
You get a bill from
Google instead of NetApp,
because it's built for Google.
Google takes support calls,
so it's supported by Google.
And additionally, we
have snapshots built in.
And these snapshots
are different
from the persistent disk
snapshots you might be used to.
So let me quickly elaborate
on these snapshots
and give you three use cases.
These snapshots
are instant to do.
Within a second, you created
a snapshot, which is basically
a photo of your file system.
You can do multiple of them.
And with that, you can build
a history of your file system,
like a versioning system.
And for the first use
case, let's assume
you want to upgrade
an application.
And you are concerned that
this upgrade might fail
and it changes
your data, and you
are left with an
unfinished upgrade which
changed your data.
You simply do a snapshot,
which is super-fast.
It's like creating a
backup in a second.
You do the upgrade.
If it works fine, delete
the snapshot afterwards.
If it fails, you
have a snapshot,
and can easily restore your data
to the last known good state.
The second use case,
which is likely
the most relevant one
for a lot of customers,
is you can enhance your
backup and recovery
processes with snapshots.
Simply build a
snapshot schedule,
which takes a snapshot every
day for the last few weeks.
And if you delete that
file, you can simply
go back to a snapshot with
a Windows File Explorer,
so the user itself
can do it in the UI.
They can simply go in there and
identify the last good version
of the file, and restore
it back to a file system.
So it helps them avoid
a help desk ticket,
and nobody likes help
desk tickets, right?
And the restore is
much, much faster.
And you can even go beyond that.
Since snapshots are so
lightweight and cheap to do,
simply take them every hour.
Take hourly snapshots.
And if you now
delete a file, you're
not only getting a
version from yesterday
from the nightly backup.
You can get a version
from last hour,
which is way more current.
So that's a super-cool
functionality
to reduce a recovery
point objective.
And the last use case, since we
are talking Windows operating
systems here, the
issue with Windows
is where it's in
danger that ransomware
infects them and encrypts
all the files on your disk.
Since you have snapshots, you
can take them every hour or so.
And you have a very
recent known good state
where your files have
not been infected.
And the cool thing is, you
can really quickly restore
the files individually, or you
can roll back the whole volume.
Within a few seconds,
half a minute or so,
you can roll it back to the
state of a last known snapshot,
and basically delete all the
encrypted files by that--
super cool.
And last thing,
it doesn't matter
how big your file system is.
Be it a terabyte or 100
terabyte, the time it takes
to create a snapshot or
roll back a snapshot,
it's all the same.
GABE WEISS: These snapshots
sound really cool.
Can you make copies of them?
Can you clone them for
other applications?
OLIVER KRAUSE: Yeah, you can.
Simply create a
snapshot of a volume,
and then create a new
volume from that snapshot.
And by the way, this process
also takes a few seconds.
Let's say you are done
in half a minute or less.
GABE WEISS: Yeah, so
the developer in me
is imagining, as we were
talking, it popped into my head
of--
we oftentimes, as
application developers,
run into a situation
where you've
got a very specific
configuration of files
on disk that reproduce a
problem for your applications.
And sometimes, reproducing
that is kind of hard.
But if you're making
these snapshots,
I can imagine a place where you
get a file system set up where
it reproduces the problem.
You snapshot it so that you
can make changes, and then
reset to be able to
reproduce the problem.
That's super-cool.
So Oliver, I'd love to dive
in a little bit deeper here.
Could you walk
through maybe where
we can find it,
and then a use case
or to where we'd want to use it?
OLIVER KRAUSE:
Yeah, the good thing
is it's directly built
into the GCP console.
Just open the GCP console,
search for Cloud Volumes.
And it's where?
It's also on the left side.
If you look up all
the services, you
will find it down at the
bottom under Partner Services.
You will also find
the documentation
in the Cloud Architecture
Center on cloud.google.com.
Regarding use cases,
I want to present two.
The first use case is a
pretty generic architecture,
which is used on thousands
of legacy applications.
You have multiple GCV EVMs
running Windows applications,
and they need a file
share to share data.
So what you do is you
simply provision a CVS share
and map it to the
Windows systems.
And we have multiple
examples where this applies.
The first one would be, for
example, VDI, Virtual Desktop
Infrastructure, where you have
SMB shares for the user home
directories, for group
directories where people
share data between
multiple users,
and for the profile shares.
Another one would be
automotive and manufacturing.
They're running a lot
of computer-aided design
and computer-aided
engineering applications.
Most of them want to talk to
a file system to share data,
so an SMB share is
the way to go here.
And that applies to many
other industry verticals.
And the last one
I want to mention
is media and entertainment.
More and more, we
see that these people
have geographically dispersed
teams working together
on a project.
And they all need to access the
same data and the same media
assets in a performant
and consistent way.
To aid these requirements,
we have a solution
called Global File
Cache, which builds
on top of CloudVolume service.
It helps you to share
out a share globally
to all the different sites--
for example LA,
London, Singapore,
while retaining excess
performance over a VAN network,
on the other side minimizing
traffic to reduce costs
and enabling global file
locking to avoid conflicts
when multiple
users try to modify
the same file at the same time.
GABE WEISS: This is
all really great.
Thank you so much, Oliver,
for being here today,
and talking through this great
partnership between Google
Cloud and NetApp using SMB file
share on Windows for Windows
application development.
It's really been a
pleasure having you here.
OLIVER KRAUSE:
Yeah, my pleasure.
Thanks for having me, Gabe.
GABE WEISS: And if
you all out there want
to dive in right away, we've
got links in the description
below to some more great
content to see this in action.
If you all have any more
ideas for customer stories
or architecture that you're
interested in learning
more about, let us
know in the comments.
And if you want to see more
of this kind of content, click
Like and Subscribe buttons.
See you next time.
[THEME MUSIC]